as balance
and to solely provide on a man if I'm
not having kids and I'm not doing
anything well that would kind of make me
lazy he's getting the short end of the
stick so I have a question what do you
guys feel like you could bring to a guy
that he couldn't just hire a maid and a
hooker to do
that's a good I made a cook and a hooker
to do so basically you need kids kids is
the only thing yeah I'm sorry to
interrupt but it's kids
no it's true but I just wanted to put
that out no it's true yeah but just
before any we knew that yeah cool
I feel like you have to match his energy
like if you if you're trying to chase
someone that has got all this drive and
ambition to be the best and they're
putting in the hours at work you also
need to be of a similar
person like you need to have that
similar personality no because men men
and women look for different things so
like men don't care about your money
they don't care about your career they
don't think no they don't care about
they don't care about what you do but I
think you still need to do that for
yourself I mean you can do what makes
you happy yeah but it doesn't but no
okay that's terrified no so you're right
you're right actually you're correct
you're correct but I'm saying like like
don't complain about the results though
so if you want to do what makes you
happy don't complain about the results
yeah so like I mean you can you can you
can like become the guy but like men
don't like guys they like women that are
like some men like guys
yeah it won't fit together or two yangs
it don't work so your question was what
do we bring to the table Yeah man
calling it from a maid or yeah like from
a from a mate like made cook and a
hooker a paid service I was gonna yeah
some hookers provide emotional safety
into Tennessee companionship there are
loads of men that I talk to that are
like Linda do you know what sometimes I
think my partner doesn't understand that
I need someone to talk to I need someone
who I can feel vulnerable to without her
throwing it back in my face
yo all right so you said men shouldn't
um they are they go to their women or
they're they're worried about what you
said it again sorry so basic wait what
so I think what days yeah the
vulnerability they wanna they want their
partner to they want to feel safe to be
vulnerable without her throwing it back
in their face when they have an argument
okay so those men should not be
emotional to their women because it's in
female nature to
if let's say there's an argument between
a man and a woman if she has ammo there
is no line that she wants she won't
cross and men arguing between men there
are lines they understand I cannot
respect exactly I can't speak about his
mother otherwise all War break loose
however if I'm arguing with a woman
and the last time she said she she came
over it there's no boundaries and so the
solution is that men should go and speak
to their male friends
about situations that are emotional to
them that are deep to them and then once
they've come up with Solutions with
their male friends they should go and
have the solutions ready for their woman
ish that's easier said than done because
I agree I actually ran a room on this on
clubhouse about this whole dynamic and
Men also said that they don't always
feel safe to speak about really
emotional things because they don't even
know how because it makes them feel less
of a guy in front of their guy that's
not really okay
but I agree that was the most common
response then my solution to that is if
you don't feel comfortable having a
conversation with your guy friends then
go to an elder like this is an encore
father figure where they're not in the
same
dynamical group settings they've done
life they've been there done that got
the t-shirt and that way you can have a
conversation with them that will allow
you to feel that oh even if I I could
feel less of a man if I'm talking to a
guy that's been there he's he's done
things that I could never imagine you
know what I'm saying that's what so what
so if a guy doesn't want to be
emotionally vulnerable he says I got my
boys for that what could you offer him
me personally yeah
I want to lie and say peace of mind
[Laughter]
but do you know what yeah I'm learning I
don't mind being like honest yeah I'm
learning that sometimes we just need to
shut up as women like no no no no
honestly like we need to shut up I like
I'm guilty of this because sometimes I
can get so emotional and I'm just like
we're all done
it's not really that big of a deal let
me just take a step back and I get more
of a positive outcome when I'm a little
bit more logical with yeah a man that
I'm romantically involved with that when
I'm all over the place and then the
second thing is listen because often
times yeah men really are telling us
what the issue is what the problem is
and then we take a we take like
girls
and he's like but you've missed
everything I was trying to say your
peace of mind if we could do that we can
offer that that a hoe and the other ones
can't do
what do you guys think I do agree with
that I think listening is so important
because they will when we'll tell you
yeah and the more time you don't listen
yeah you just don't because you you want
to hear what you want to hear yeah
what suits you what makes you feel good
you feel me so we don't listen that's
very true I'm not saying I'm not gonna
say everyone
yeah bombarded but I think there's a big
percentage of women that don't listen we
don't listen and we talk on top of men
as well we talk over them
as well I think we need to allow men to
be men and women need to be women and I
think they're yeah yeah yeah that is
something that's so important there's
too many women trying to be that are
trying to be men
that's me what do you think no that's I
like your others you're not you're not
alone that's like a common um roller
tomasi always says women become the men
they want to marry yeah so they get good
with their finances they get in shape
they do all the things that they want
yeah in a guy would you say yeah that's
what happened to me basically but my
relationship went down in the toilet
because
I was the man like I wasn't even allowed
them to pay for dinner or offer me a
dinner
I'll do that you want to go out on a
weekend I'll pay how long did I lost
well the last one's just six months
yeah
yeah I know I know now
I went to that healing process yeah
I'm gonna make appointment yeah I did I
didn't went in Spain I didn't wear on a
holiday with my girlfriend yeah I just
know I just know where they're going to
think no I I no no I just sitting here
in London and I was like you know what I
think there's something's wrong with me
it's not me then like it's not that
other people are it's our accountability
that's me probably I'm being a prick as
well so I should work on myself and
being honest with me accept what are my
limits and what I should ill might post
traumas and like choose up